et bien bonjour bonjour à tous bonjour à
tous je suis très content de vous
retrouver alors je vous retrouve pour
vous donner un rendez-vous un rendez
vous le 29 mars donc c'est bientôt le 29
mars à 18 heures vous pouvez venir soit
à aubervilliers dans notre amphithéâtre
soit vous pouvez vous connecter sur les
réseaux se le webinaire qui aurait dû en
même temps donc à peu près une centaine
de personnes en présentiel et puis
j'espère plein de monde sur les réseaux
et là je vais évoquer sous l'égide de
jean jacques seymour quête analystes et
un économistes journalistes d'outre-mer
bien connu en compagnie d'olivier sudrie
olivier sudrie professeur d'économie
nous allons évoquer des sujets qui sont
des sujets extrêmement important la
cherté de la vie dans les territoires
d'outre-mer ça tout le monde en parle
mais nous on va expliquer comment on
peut sortir d'une telle situation
couplée avec la production locale le
deuxième sujet ce sera le sujet des
monopoles parce que les monopoles nous
nous disons chez adobe mais vous ne
savez depuis très longtemps qu'ils ne
sont entrés vendre et ce parti
responsable de la situation économique
et des inégalités que nous avons que
l'on constate aujourd'hui leur et
territoires d'outre-mer et puis enfin le
troisième sujet qui est le smig
outre-mer puisque nous disons
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas de
surrémunération dans les territoires
d'outre-mer mais qu'il ya une
sensibilisation et il faut augmenter le
smic de 20% et alors on va vous dire
comment comment on le finance qui paye
tout ça va être absolument dit vous
allez pouvoir nous poser toutes les
questions je répondrai à toutes les
questions que vous nous poserait nous
aurons ce débat à la fois dans la salle
était à travers le webinaire à travers
des réseaux pour vous inscrire il faut
vous inscrire en cliquant sur le lien
qui s'affiche dessous et j'espère que
vous serez très nombreux donc rendez
vous le 29 mars 18h heure de paris à des
taux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en